So, we have seen that we want
the cache to be small and fast,
but not too small because then
it keeps very little stuff.
So, that it has very few hits.
So, what are the cache sizes that
we have actually observed in real
processors.
There is a complication there,
in that modern processors.
Usually have several
caches not just one.
So depending on which
cache are we talking about
it might be larger or smaller.
So let's look at caches that we call L1,
or level one caches which are the caches
that directly service the read and
write requests from the processor.
So when the processor wants to read or
write, it first goes to the L1
cache to check if it has a hit.
If the L1 cache has a miss, then things
get complicated because before we go to
the main memory, we go to other caches.
And in several lessons,
we will actually see how that works.
But for now, let's just see how
big are these level one caches.
In recent processors,
typical sizes of the L1 cache
have been 16 to 64 kilobytes.
This is large enough to get about
90% hit rate, meaning only one-tenth
of all the accesses from the processor
end up going beyond this cache.
Yet, these are still small enough to
have the hit time that is equal to
1 to 3 processor cycles.
So we spend very few
process cycles waiting for
the data to come back from this cache,
if it's a hit.
Recall that memories have hundreds
of cycles, co this is very,
very fast compared to the memory.